democrats are fine-tuning their plan b
as they edge closer to a deal on
president biden's multi-trillion dollar
social spending bill the amount congress
wants to spend on the measure has
dropped significantly forcing the
president to make concessions in an
effort to get it passed that means
progressive democrats will most likely
lose programs they've vigorously fought
for such as free community college and
medicare expansion christina raffini is
at the white house with more christina
good morning
good morning dana well you can't always
get what you want that's the message
president biden delivered to dissenting
members of his own party this week
telling them it's time to learn to love
or at least like the bill they've got
compromise is not a dirty word but for
progressive and moderate democrats at
odds over the multi-trillion dollar
democratic spending bill it's proving
difficult the alternative is not a
larger package the alternative is
nothing the original 3.5 trillion dollar
plan is being whittled down to about 2
trillion dollars in an effort to appease
senators joe manchin and kirsten cinema
who opposed the initial price tag but
you feel like a deal is close
now democrats must decide amongst
themselves what to keep and what to cut
from climate change to expanded medicare
the green aspects of this the climate
aspects of it
in terms of the health care we have a
couple down
that
just made a decision one decision that
both moderates and progressives so far
have agreed on universal pre-k
under the president's build back better
plan the federal government would pay
the startup costs for every state to
offer pre-kindergarten education this is
not politics for me at all
it is just about doing what is best for
kids but another educational provision
free community college a passion project
for first lady jill biden didn't make
the cut i'm going to get it done
and if i don't i'll be sleeping alone
for a long time at a town hall on
thursday the president acknowledged
other programs like paid paternal leave
will be scaled back and adding vision
and dental coverage to medicare now
seems unlikely still he said the
compromise bill is a step in the right
direction so i'm prepared to do the
things that can get done now that can
begin to change the lives of ordinary
americans to give them a fighting chance
there is also disagreement about how to
pay for the bill several proposals are
being drafted including one that would
tax billionaires the 700 wealthiest
americans president biden leaves for a
trip for europe next week and is hoping
lawmakers can finalize the framework
before he goes wheels up michelle
all righty christina thank you